So
today we will try and understand
different religions in the right
perspective by trying to understand what
the scriptures of that religion had to
speak about almighty
God. Due to time
limitations we will discuss the three
major religions of the world that is
Christianity, Islam and Hinduism as well
as Judaism.
First we'll discuss and try to
understand Hinduism in the right
perspective by trying to understand the
concept of God in
Hinduism. If you ask a common Hindu how
many gods does he believe in? Some will
say three, some will say 33, some will
say 100 gods, some will say thousand,
some will say 33 crores, 330 million
gods.
But if you ask a learned
Hindu who is well versed with the
scriptures, he will tell you that Hindus
should believe and worship only one
God. But the common Hindu, he believes
in a philosophy known as
pantheism. The common Hindu says
everything is God. The tree is God, the
sun is God, the moon is God, the monkey
is God, the snake is God, the human
being is God.
What we Muslims they say everything is
God's. G O D with an apostrophe. S. We
Muslims they say everything belongs to
God. The tree belongs to God. The sun
belongs to God. The moon belongs to God.
The snake belongs to God. The monkey
belongs to God. The human belongs to
God. So the major difference between the
Muslims and the Hindus is the common
Hindu says everything is God. We Muslims
they say everything is God's go O D with
an apostrophe s. So the major difference
is only the apostrophe
s. If we can solve this difference of
apostrophes the Hindus and the Muslims
will be
united. How do we do it? Allah says in
3:64 come to common terms as between us
and you which is the first term Allahill
Allah that we worship none but one
Allah. When we read the Hindu scriptures
we know the Hindu scriptures are divided
into two broad categories. The the shri
and the smuti. Shri means those
scriptures of Hinduism which they
believe is from almighty god and smiti
are those which they believe are written
by human beings. So the highest amongst
all the Hindu scriptures in the shi are
the vedas then you have the
upanishads in the smuti those scriptures
which are written by human being you
have many you have the puranas you have
the itas the raman the mahabharat and
the most commonly read hindu scripture
the bhagat gita it's mentioned in the
bhagat gita chapter number 7 verse
number 20 all those whose intelligence
has been stolen by material desires.
They worship
demigods. Here Bhagat Gita is saying in
chapter number 7 verse number 20, the
materialistic people they worship
demigods. They worship false gods. They
they do idol
worship. When we read the opanishads,
it's mentioned in the chandoga panishad
chapter number six section number two
verse number one.
It's a Sanskrit quotation which means
God is only one without a
second. It's mentioned in
Satasaranishad chapter number six verse
number
nana of that god he has no parents he
has got no lords. Almighty God has got
no mother. He has got no father. He has
got no superior.
It's mentioned in Sitharan chapter
number four verse number
19. Of that God there is no image.
Pratima is a Sanskrit word which means
an image. It means a photograph. It
means a painting. It means a picture. It
means a portrait. It means a sculpture.
It means a statue. It means an idol.
So chapter number 4 19
says of that God there is no image there
is no photograph there is no picture
there is no painting there is no
portrait there is no sculpture there is
no idol there is no statue